Four Seasons upon us and while I've
talked about what I feel are the titles
people are looking forward to the most I
think I should do a similar list but for
the new titles so if you're one of those
people who are new and looking for
something to watch this fall or if you
simply want to see what this season has
in store for us in terms of new shows
then welcome to the list today I'll
share what I think are the top 10 titles
people seem to be most excited for this
season and I'll be excluding sequels
this time around berserk of gluttony
opens up the list and I sure am excited
for this one
[Music]
all right
berserk of gluttony is one of the series
I've seen floating around on the
internet for quite some time now I've
always been interested in getting up to
speed with it and really anticipate its
anime adaptation judging from what I've
seen in the communities I'm not the only
one berserk of gluttony has all the
looks of one of those edgy Rise Against
the World plots like Ari fioreta and you
know how much I enjoyed that one and
just like a lot of similar shows the
protagonist fate graphite has to deal
with a pretty annoying handicap he's
already someone who's at the lowest of
the low and to make matters worse he
gets saddled with a seemingly useless
skill one that makes him constantly
hungry however killing a thief soon
reveals the Sinister mechanics behind
the skill the ability to take souls and
their respective Powers with this skill
this man who's at the bottom of the food
chain may have just found the answer to
strike back against the cruel situation
that fate has bestowed upon him yeah the
summary pretty much sums up what you
should expect expect quite a lot of
awesome moments starring our protagonist
some much wanted edge and a pretty good
plot if what people said is to be
delivered I personally can't wait to see
how this turns out as an anime
mama
we then move on to the world of careered
manoir with the returners magic should
be special
whatever
with Korean titles getting more and more
traction these days possibly headlined
by the hype of solo leveling I'm not
surprised we're getting more adaptations
from them one of the comparatively less
heralded but just as exciting titles is
coming this next season and it's a
returner's magic should be special the
tales of the world ravaged by war
between magicians and Labyrinth beasts
when it took an entire party of elite
adventurers to defeat the first dragon
things already look dire enough but
things quickly go from bad to worse in
the aftermath just when all hope seems
lost for the last magician desia Herman
he gets sent back in time back to when
he spent his day studying in the magic
Academy Hebron aiming to use his second
chance wisely he looks to fix the
mistakes of the past and save his
comrades ultimately seeking to pull
everyone out of the awful fate that
awaits them time travel stories like
this have often captivated a lot of the
anime viewing audience and I'm positive
this one's not going to be any different
I really wonder how well the plot works
when you give it a backdrop Of The World
of Magic but I'm pretty sure there's
going to be a lot of cool fights ahead
[Music]
foreign
s who really really really really really
really love you is up next
[Music]
thank you
say that again five reallys and that's a
mouthful of a title and it's really
fitting what a wild show this one is
fresh middle school graduate rentaro
manages to confess to the girl he loves
unfortunately though he gets rejected
marking his hundredth failure undeterb
he then goes to a shrine and prays for a
girlfriend in high school and as they
say we should be careful what we wish
for because naturally things go awfully
wrong sure he gets confessed to
immediately and apparently a hundred
soul mates await all to make up for the
hundred rejections funnily enough but
that wish of his comes with a catch if
any one of the girls gets into a
relationship with him she dies
no ifs no buts now with a hundred soul
mates ready and waiting it's the
ultimate test for rent Ro and how he'll
juggle these relationships is the time
right for one of the insane Harem
rom-coms in modern anime we're gonna
find out when full season hits
up next we have the range Detective
foreign
with a title like that you'd expect one
of two things a serious Mystery Show
featuring detectives or where things go
over the top and turns into a comedy
this one Falls squarely in the latter
and it's one of the really fun series
about the pleasure of reading who knew
that a gag series would work so well
with the mystery detective setup sure
you get the mystery solving aspects but
when the series stars are dysfunctional
Duo of an overly eager officer and an
eccentric veteran who looks nothing like
the part and seems to have nothing to do
with Detective work entertaining things
happen but who knows maybe the upstart
dodomaru may be the key to Ron returning
to His Glory Days as a nice detective
with this series I can't promise a deep
plot nor can I vouch for anything is
compelling in terms of mysteries at the
actual Mystery Show can offer however
what the show can give you is a lot of
fun there's a lot of quirkiness to the
characters as they go about solving
cases and they do a great job helping
the comedic aspects of the show watch
out for this one if you're up for some
unwinding this fall
writer number six is ragna crimson
[Music]
Trail
if you are for something more familiar
more traditional then maybe wrong in a
crimson might tickle your fancy it's a
pretty tight fantasy Adventure we've got
here hearkening to the days of the good
old medieval RPGs where two individuals
team up to take on the dragons that
Ruled the Land ragna and Crimson may be
as uneasy as allies can be but one goal
binds the duo together destroying the
dragonlords and freeing the
post-apocalyptic World from their room
set in a world that feels oddly familiar
yet has an air of mystery to it Ragnar
Crimson is one of my top recommendations
for people looking for a thrilling
adventure this fall short the premise
may not seem that special at first but
there are some twists especially with
Ragnar that ultimately shake things up
drastically down the line things can get
really unpredictable for sure as daring
Dragon Hunter teams up with a possibly
straight up Loose Cannon in Crimson
there's a lot of combustible elements at
play here
next we have Shangri-La Frontier
[Laughter]
if you ever felt like you never got
tired of gaming even being the worst
games imaginable you'd like to hit up
pretty well with rakuro the protagonist
of Shangri-La Frontier I mean this is a
guy who's made it his life goal his
mission statement to find every awful
game under the sun and beat them glitchy
messes and everything not a problem
however things change when he suffers
burnout before getting introduced to
shangri-law Frontier supposedly the best
and most awesome VR game in town will
the skills he accumulated from mastering
bottom of the barrel games come in handy
as he takes this plunge and uncovers the
secrets of this new game we'll have to
wait till four to find out but this is
already looking mighty promising for a
video game show the premise is already
pretty nice and it's one of the video
game shows that places some emphasis on
strategy and teamwork The Source
material has gone pretty detailed with
the actual game mechanics aspect and I
expect this approach to catch Gamers
attention in anime form 2.
Undead unluck is a rank 4.
oh my more
some people just have an affinity with
being unlucky like Fuko izumo after her
favorite manga ended there just seems to
be no point in keeping life going
nothing good comes out from her after
all especially with what seems like a
curse that brings Misfortune to people
around her however it was her attempt to
end herself that lets her path cross
with Andy an immortal man who also
wishes for death together the two of
them team up all with the goal of giving
Andy the best death possible a task
easier said than done especially when
you factor in a shady organization
that's taken an interest in the duo a
unique series that's making some
headways in Shonen Jump Undead unlocked
due for an anime adaptation as expected
from a lot of the Pioneers from the
magazine Undead unlocked dazzles
audiences with creative Powers an Apple
Dash of fan service characters with
presents and an immersive adventure for
us to follow despite the supposedly dark
premise Margie Calendar's Undead analog
drops this October
third place is the Apothecary Diaries
if there's one thing that makes me happy
doing these supplementary lessons and my
seasonal previews is the fact that it
gives me a second chance to look at the
roster as we get closer to the season
and pick out really promising shows like
this one Apothecary Diaries is a drama
set in ancient China and it revolves
around 17 year old Malmo kidnapped at a
young age and forced to work as a
servant in a palace she catches the
attention of jinshi a eunuch who sees
her for what she is a girl with a talent
for medicine owing to her experiences in
her youth thus begins her new Journey as
she utilizes her talents in solving
medical Mysteries within the emperor's
court it's been a while since we've had
one of these kinds of shows done in a
similar vein with Jonah of the Dawn or
snow white with red hair these shows
always end up being pleasant surprises
some good watches if you're one who
prefers slow builds and character drama
plus some beautiful Aesthetics this
could be the new of the season for
fans of genres that don't typically
become mainstream
laugh
and if you're up for slow Burns that
have strong Aesthetics and themes you're
in for a treat with freeren Beyond
Journey's End
[Music]
former too often we're concerned with
the journey the Grand Adventure to
defeat the Demon Lord to claim the holy
grail and whatnot but what happens when
it's all over what happens when you go
on your separate ways as peace gets
restored to the land and to that the
fact that you're gonna long outlive your
friends and you can see where I'm going
right that's the gist of freering Beyond
Journey's End where the elfrin is left
alone outliving all of her companions
finding comfort in a New Journey with a
human Apprentice named Fern a journey
that will take them through the various
places that made up much of free Reds
past I've seen this title compared a lot
with to your eternity and it's easy to
see why the overall Vibes feel the same
and free event deals with the idea of a
long-living being finding out that there
really is more to learn about the world
and its inhabitants the show is visually
pleasing and it promises to be a
thematically strong Journey full of
emotional ups and downs
foreign
Pluto
[Music]
unlike the long sentences that make up a
lot of modern anime's titles there's not
much you can infer from the title Pluto
besides the fact that it's a Sci-Fi
series maybe but man it's one of the
best ones you can have amongst the
classics being a sister story to the
legendary Astro Boy it tells of the
death of the legendary robot Mont Blanc
the single Flashpoint that sets esteemed
detective gesicked into action it's this
investigation that puts him in position
to encounter The Entity Pluto and a
conspiracy to wreck human robot
coexistence robots who participated in
the great Asian War are in danger and
guess it must put his wits and skills to
their limits in order to save the
fragile World Order Before Time runs out
on him one of the classics in the world
of sci-fi anime Pluto is a Thrill Ride
That You're Not Gonna Wanna Miss it's
got very strong writing as a manga and
I'm excited to see how well the strong
themes and scenes present themselves in
anime form anime Watchers will finally
get to experience one of urasawa's best
series and considering how acclaimed
titles like monster are we can
definitely all get hyped for this one
foreign
[Music]
and that more or less wraps up the top
10 most anticipated new anime for fall
2023. I've had good memories of past
Four Seasons and I think this one is
going to be no different some great
shows in a variety of genres with
something for everyone do tell me what
you think of the list or what you think
should have been included and if you
still got time why don't you drop by the
channel and check out the other videos
that I have in store for you too thanks
for watching hope you have a great day
and I'll see you next time